we had john lovitz on yesterday um he
was already just scheduled to appear to
talk about a new film of his um and he
told a couple of noor mcdonald stories
and we just see how
folks are responding to it and how we
felt about the sudden passing of norm
mcdonald although it might not have been
so sudden but it was to so many people
and uh i figured let's just
keep talking about them because we've
gone down a youtube wormhole just one
after another afternoon is conan
appearances his letterman appearances
his snl turd ferguson appearances you
know um his espy uh awards emceeing and
of course his appearances on roasts and
that's how we bring in one of my
favorite people on planet earth a
sweetheart who's also one of the
funniest guys i know
on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line here on the rich eisen show
is the roast master general himself
jeffrey ross how are you jeffrey oh
great to be here great to have you such
a strange strange circumstances rich
so uh
did you know or was there any inner
circle that might have known about his
illness
jeffrey
well
you know he always had some weird
medical stuff he was he looked a little
different sometimes
no one really thought to ask questions
and he didn't he didn't show that
vulnerability
um just recently
i heard that he told
two
close friends
that he had cancer as a child
and then he had cancer again for the
last decade or so
so it was something he kept to himself
he didn't want it to affect his comedy
the way people accepted his jokes the
way people talk to him he didn't want to
be pitied is the message that i got um
because it does hurt to not be able to
say goodbye it does hurt
uh for the living but it also must have
been torture for for norm rich to to go
in it by himself like that
well i mean i can't imagine if i was
sick like that i'd want all the love and
support
and you'd receive it as well and i'm
sure norm would have also you know and
it did appear that he did channel it
jeffrey into
into his comedy there
he did
a stand-up um
[Music]
joke
yeah and i i saw that video over the
last 24 hours where
you know we in the news business say
that somebody lost their battle to
cancer
and the joke was well you know
somebody's going
that the last report is that you're a
loser
and that technically when you die so
does the cancer so shouldn't it be
called a draw
a double knockout that's what he said
you know and
it adds a little bit i guess of
i was blown away that it
do you think that was born out of his
own experience
that he was going through at the time
believe it was on his mind
um also when cancer runs in your family
as it does in mind and many many others
right
it does make you think well there's a
good chance i'm
gonna get it
and you do guide your life like that my
mom got sick when she was
uh very young and
it always thought to me well man that's
just what happens in our family
i guess it'll be me someday
at a certain point i just started to go
well it doesn't have to be if i
if i don't do those habits those
addictions those things that
may cause cancer i may get lucky
um not everybody gets cancer for doing
the wrong thing but
you know it's a sneaky it's a sneaky
bastard
but um
i feel like some of that
gun to his head knowing his face might
be numbered
may have fueled his
fearlessness
he's the guy that despite being mourned
by don o meyer and nbc would
still go out and do those oj jokes
he wasn't afraid to take chances and i
think part of it was because
he had nothing to lose he was alive
jeffrey ross the roast master general
here on the rich eisen show when'd you
first meet him nor mcdonald oh man i met
him
um
it was probably 90 or 91.
i was just transitioning from open micro
in new jersey
to opening mc act and comedy clubs
and man rich i was excited catcher
rising star princeton there's like eight
shows over five days or something i was
really gonna like get some stage time
and
um
rich boss very funny guy was the middle
act none of us knew each other and norm
mcdonald flew in from toronto
he had just done a bunch of uh
was it sajak's or something
who had the late night show
or was it uh yeah
he did for a while he did
yeah i think it was sage
and um
he hit on that show and became like you
know he was popping but no one in
america really knew him right
and
norm was
this is 91 you know that tight this is
when america especially in new jersey
most people wanted to see andrew dice
clay in an arena doing nursery rhymes
now norm comes in with this like you
know
button-down shirt the blazer
and
hey yeah
like you couldn't barely understand them
and
and his material was tight tight
and
callbacks and crafted and honed and
economical use of the language like it
was fascinating for a comedian but if
you were just a couple of knuckleheads
with which are dates
to catch princeton that you're used to
seeing hickory dickory dock yes
yes
he didn't bomb
he didn't hit all the time he bombed
probably
three out of the eight shows
and
this is one of the craziest things and
i've never seen it before rich
after the shows
as people were paying their checks
norm would go to the exit
and greet every single customer
come on
the more he bombed the longer he stayed
there
it was so hilarious and
it makes made him a mystery to me an
enigma to me right away why he loved
that part of it
and if he killed
he'd go right out the back to the green
room and break out a deck of cards and
we'd play poker he'd love to play poker
so
my first experiences with him were very
very
uh
all in we should say
jeffrey ross here on the rich eisen show
yesterday lovitz told a couple of
stories one where you know he
um
about about his commitment and that when
you told him not to do something that
just made him want to do it more and how
they were performing for some sharks at
a biloxi mississippi casino all these
guys and ladies who were comped to see
him and love it's together and
people uh in the audience had a big
problem with how filthy how blue that
norm was working that made him only work
more blue and the end of the story was
uh lovett said that they got he he
he got them banned from the casino for
five years and i'm like why because he
really because that's what he did on the
stage he goes no he was he's busted
counting cards that's what he said
and so much
[Laughter]
oh my god and then told the story of the
sagitt roast where they he was told not
to work blue and and so he or he was
told to tone it down and then he went
the completely other way is that what
happened
i had not heard that he was told
to turn it down right
i thought he made you told to turn it
off just
i thought he made the choice to
go so soft that that was the joke
because saggett's roast was one of the
few roasts
where
it was mostly comics mostly body comics
and at that point saga was really
digging into that stuff right
aristocrats movie had just come out bob
was having this resurgence of dirty
daddy and uh
you know really a contrast from his full
house persona and we were all went in
really deep and
i purposely
what wrote my speech without one curse
word just to make a point that you
didn't have to be funny to be dirty
right and and that was my spin on it
norm took it one step further
and did farmers almanac type
you know that we're you know like hey
clarence leachman
people say you're over the hill but
don't listen listen to him you'll never
be over the hill not with that car you
drive
and we looked at him like is he having a
stroke
[Laughter]
but i already knew norm will always go
for the best joke the way he went on snl
the way he would on late night shows you
know publicist be damned he wanted to
have
most provocative joke that the comics
would talk about the next day but on
this show
he did a conceptual piece to throw
softballs around the deus in an
affectionate sort of way and you can see
when you listen back the first few jokes
people are kind of polite laughs nervous
laughs you know i'm a producer i'm
almost panicking right yes
like what is he tanking this on purpose
uh we already had artie lang not show up
you know we don't want this to be a
disaster
but about five jokes in
um
i can start giggling i start to sense
that something's happening
and they buy it the audience by the end
they should roaring as if he was as if
he was
andrew nice clay but doing these very
soft uh jokes um and i think it was a
nice uh de noma or a nice chapter from
his post snl
where he was provocative and pushed the
envelope especially with these
oj jokes um you know he's the one who
famously said well it's official murder
is now legal in california
um
and you know this would really route
people up you know he was the one who
said uh that the jury's in deliberation
so now they can either free him or get
their heads cut off
and
you didn't hear a lot of that kind of
humor on tv
and
and now we live in a world where
you almost can't do any of the rich you
know you talk about cancel culture
maybe norm
you know this is a bold statement maybe
he didn't want to live in a world full
of donald myers
everybody's trying to take everybody's
cancel them everyone's trying to cancel
everybody
so you know maybe
i wish i got to talk to him at the end
there
um but i didn't
maybe he just
maybe his body just gave in and
maybe he lost his fight
jeffrey ross here on the rich show um
hey before i let you go uh i you put in
perspective for us i mean letterman
chose him as the last stand-up comic and
his run
uh on his show i mean that was what what
a spot what a gig what a
what a what an opportunity as well as an
honor for letterman to say out of all
the standups that have been on the show
you're my choice to be the last person
to speak other than me on my historic
television run
what what is norm mcdonald's legacy
amongst the the comedy community and
everything else that you can
put into words jeffrey
well
somebody that you admired in that
he
he took his career in a patient way
he turned almost everything down
he only wanted to work when he knew he
was going to be hilarious he wasn't
thirsty for attention
he he wanted to be great or not be there
at all
and
that that is something that really
more comedians i think need to
understand you don't need to be at every
party every show you can say no and when
you say no you become a mystery an
enigma and people want to see you even
more
that rich on top of this economic use of
words go back and listen to the jokes he
written
they were perfect there wasn't an extra
syllable other than an occasional
canadian a
you know there was nothing extra in
those jokes
and that that to me was his legacy and
he's also a great guy and a great friend
jeffrey ross uh you wrote a beautiful
piece everyone should go check it out on
your you put into words um kind of what
you just uh you just mentioned here on
this show
go to uh at the real jeffrey ross on
instagram hit the bio to read that piece
i love you jeffrey ross let's uh i love
i love you more buddy and i i just saw
you speaking of provocative comedy you
really have some wonderful moments in
the vice film currently streaming called
911 too soon
about i haven't seen that yet
and
the return of comedy in new york city in
the weeks after 9 11. well you know i've
been talking to you about that for a
long time being at that hefner roast
just a few weeks after um
you know the attack on on the trade
center in the country um what a night
that was i haven't seen that so you what
what'd you think of that that's out
there
i loved it it's about as a full-length
film it covers uh where we all the
comics were and what we're doing when
the trade center fell i was home
uh with uh dave chappelle and adam
ferrara
evacuated to my house and we really
thought you know this is it comedy we're
not gonna be laughing again anytime soon
and i wrote letters to the friars into
two hefner at comedy central and i said
if we don't do this show the terrorists
win and that was not a cliche back then
that was something that would really
happen right that would be half the
million dollars we were raising for the
twin towers fun would be would never
happen and it wound up being you know a
highlight of my career and a highlight
for new york at that time and people go
well three weeks after 9 11 of course
you could do a show but when people
forget and you'll remember rich is that
we were walking around in a dust bowl a
human
gospel yep
you couldn't write jokes you couldn't
think straight it was a mission if you
were doing comedy you weren't showing up
stoned wandering to a comedy club you
were a man a woman on a mission
and
the film really shows that it shows
people like gilbert gottfried and bob
saget and
and really going for it and a lot of the
saturday live people and you know mayor
giuliani's famous moment with lorne
michaels whatever you think of giuliani
now he really is portrayed in a
fascinating
courageous way in this film and there's
a lot of really good funny moments i
highly recommend 9 11 too soon i will i
i will talk more about it and now that
it is looked great in it very
sophisticated laser a big chair
like a big maca
guy who knows what he's talking about
you know what it was truly one of being
on that dais that night um was truly one
of the greatest moments of my life to be
very honest with you um and just because
being a native new yorker to be there at
the time and i'm such a an aficionado of
comedy and rose and the person who put
me on that dais was you and you know it
was one of those times where i'm going
out and it was really weird to even go
out to a social event in those weeks
after 9 11 in new york city but i just
forced myself to do it that's when i ran
into you that night and you know we had
a nice chat uh we'd never met before i
told you i loved your uh be arthur joke
i think i had you at hello and i said
that and um and then you're like do you
have a tuxedo
in town i'm like yeah sure and you
you're like come to the roast in two
days if you're around and i was and i
did and i'll never forget it
and we have been friends ever since and
it meant a lot that
you know friendships these roasts bring
people together and here we are 20 years
later talking about it and we've shared
a million meals and a million laughs
together yeah and uh these things really
do live on
uh whether it's norms performance people
still talk about it bob sagas roast or
or or that night where we all got
together and defied the terror in new
york and do you remember any jokes rich
did anybody come after you at that time
nobody came after no man because it
first started i was so damn far down the
dais i was in between
i was i was second to last on the left
and uh i was in between the amazing
crescent and frankie in the middle uh
munis and then uh
and then because there was a fight a
prize fight in madison square garden and
the roast started so late people got up
and i was a seat filler and i wound up
being five uh seats from the the podium
uh in between joey pants joe pantaliano
and who knew it uh friars club member
patty hearst and i'll never forget being
there for the joke and all the jokes and
wondering what the hell was gilbert
godfrey attempting and why everyone was
so laughing about it it was the
aristocrats joke and there was a whole
nother movie made out of that i'll never
forget it
love you jeff ross
right back at you thanks for calling
thanks you guys very cathartic thank you
oh you're the best that's jeffrey ross